- Vers l'an 1000, plus de
500 ans avant Jacques-Cartier.
- Depuis longtemps, nous savons
que l'arrivée des vikings en
Amérique du Nord datait de plus
ou moins 1000 ans grâce à la
datation par le carbone 14.
Mais une nouvelle méthode
a permis de détecter
avec beaucoup plus de précision
une année précise
durant laquelle les vikings
ont foulé le sol de L'Anse-aux-
Meadows : précisément en 1021.
1000 ans plus tard, en 2021,
Brigitta Wallace cosigne
l'article publié cette semaine
dans la prestigieuse revue
scientifique "Nature".
"Ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
n'y étaient ni avant ni après,
mais on sait maintenant
qu'en 1021, ils y étaient."
Dans les années 70,
l'archéologue d'origine suédoise
effectuait des fouilles
archéologiques à L'Anse-aux-
Meadows pour Parcs Canada.
Elle a découvert des morceaux
de bois bien préservés
dans un marais. Ils avaient
vraisemblablement été coupés
par des outils européens.
Elle les a entreposés
au congélateur
pendant des décennies.
Auparavant, les chercheurs
utilisaient la technique
de datation au carbone 14
pour détecter l'âge d'un objet.
Mais les résultats étaient
très imprécis.
Puis, deux chercheurs
de l'Université de Groningue,
aux Pays-Bas, ont contourné
l'obstacle avec une méthode
originale grâce à un rayonnement
cosmique daté.
Ils ont demandé à voir
les morceaux de bois trouvés par
Mme Wallace. Ils y ont détecté
la trace d'un événement cosmique
précis : celui de l'année 993.
Il a suffi de compter le nombre
de cernes entre cette année-là
et le dernier cercle au bord de
l'écorce pour déterminer la date
à laquelle l'arbre a été abattu.
Tout pointe vers l'année 1021.
Pendant toutes ces années
sur le terrain, l'archéologue
n'a jamais voulu lire
les "Sagas", ces fameux textes
de tradition orale racontant
l'épopée des vikings.
Elle ne voulait pas être
influencée par ces récits
semi-légendaires. Par contre,
elle était convaincue
que ces morceaux de bois, eux,
en avaient long à raconter.
Ici Stéphanie Blanchet,
Radio-Canada, H